sur les réseaux sociaux pierre ménès
officialisé son départ de touche pas à
mon poste une internaute lui a demandé
quand il revenait dans l'émission rien à
voir mais à quand votre prochain dans
votre prochaine dans tpm paie pas prévu
je suis trop fatigué par mes
déplacements
le vendredi un autre internaute penser
qu'il n'était plus dans tpm pekka rinne
des pales sa place dans le programme
il a dit je pensais de votre
collaboration était terminée je pense
que vous n'êtes pas dans votre élément
dans cette émission et pierre ménès a
répondu c'est pas faux j'arrête vraiment
pour faire attention à ma santé parce
que c'est vrai qu'il était fatigué l'eau
pierre et que maintenant il fait une
nouvelle émission le vendredi où il est
sur le terrain
donc c'était un petit peu compliqué
surtout pour lui ou est ce que vous
aimez pierre dans l'émission roide il
était elle est plutôt agréable va vous
manquer ou pas franchement bon pas
forcément mais on a l'impression que tu
en a rien à carrer le souci c'est que il
peut avoir des problèmes de santé ça on
peut comprendre mais il aurait plus le
prêt de prévenir par exemple avant deux
mois on en a préparé un petit ensemble
un par sms 1 voilà ça se passe très bien
on a bien à la presse je pense que il a
dû voilà il s'exprime beaucoup sur les
réseaux à la motion veut pas du tout en
plus je laime bien pire au voilà ça va
je voulais dire un truc tory non c'est
bien nommé il a une grande bouche il
aurait pu aussi le prévenir aussi comme
tu es comme tu dis voilà il arrive à
ouvrir quand ça bouge toute l'année donc
là il peut prévenir aussi avant de
partir juste moi c'est vraiment mon avis
fait vibrer et je voulais juste revenir
sur marie bouché on a vraiment besoin de
visibilité parce que ce travail récent
excès quand même par l'apli qui sont pas
ces jus il ya des sports hyper visuel
sport nature des 60 ans je suis fan
fauteuils sont à 30 cm du sol et ils
auraient peur
ces visuels du coup il ya toute la
matière pour ça pour ça se voit donc à
vous les médias de vous y mettiez que
toi qui es que toi qui arrive à nous
inviter matin avant cela il convient de
parler du maître l'inquiète pas il ya
des grandes choses qui vont être faites
dans les médias qui va voir j'espère en
avril tu vas voir que ça va être énorme
ce qui va se passer parce que avec avec
la la la ministre il se prépare des
choses et vous allez voir que les balles
et les personnes handicapées vont être
de plus en plus représentées à la
télévision française savoir il ya une
grande mesure qui va arriver en avril
c'est une bonne chose c'est ce que c'est
il ya seulement 0,8 pour cent les
personnes en situation de handicap qui
sont présents à la télévision sur 12
millions de français viennent faire les
choses bien merci
si pour ce chiffre à la maxime qui a
encore bossé donc voilà donc pierre
ménès il viendra nous voir quand même en
invité parfois voulait réagir
oui en fait moi je trouve que il aurait
dû rester encore un peu
je serai bien que celles-ci voulaient
mais beaucoup c'est votre faute je laime
bien alors je le préfère dans le foot
ici je trouve qu'il n'avait pas encore
trouvé sa place oui on va pas se mentir
il aimait pas les déguisements pas les
happenings mais je trouve qu'il aurait
pu apporter un peu plus et de mon point
de vue je trouve qu'il renonce un peu
vite voilà d'accord il cotait va
peut-être venir pierre valax gentil
salaires en tout cas il est toujours le
bienvenu suis venir nous voir
il sera bienvenu dans tpm